Vanessa I'm so happy for you I'm so
proud that you're receiving this honor
tonight I'm I wanted to be there so much
to be with you and and to salute you in
person I'm right across the channel in
Paris and I had to be there in rehearse
and so I couldn't make it but you've
been my friend you've been my idol
you've been my mentor since the 60s you
put starch in my spine when I felt that
maybe I was getting to be too much of an
activist you showed me what being the
greatest actor of all time looked like
and and I've loved you for so long my
name my daughter after you and I'm so
jealous that mural is there but I can't
be there and Meryl is there two of the
great living actors of all time and what
an amazing experience we had in that
movie Julia to be able to work with you
to to be able to love you like Lillian
loved you loved Julia to to play scenes
where I could look up at you and hold
your beautiful long hands in mine and
and those are days and weeks and months
that I will never forget I feel so lucky
that I could share that with you and and
so lucky that we were in a movie in
which Meryl Streep made her her film
debut and you have something very
important in common the two of you I
once read that mural mural talk about
acting as a profession of empathy and I
think that one of the reasons that you
and Meryl are are so profoundly gifted
is because of your hearts your enormous
empathy and understanding of how people
work how the world works your care and
love for others and you Vanessa you you
put that in
action over and over and over again in
such a brave and profound way you've led
the way for so many of us and I send you
all my love and deep congratulations
you